Oh no.I remember.
I remember now why i abandoned you.
I closed my eyes for one second and you try to betray me.
I saw my life flash before my eyes.
Oh,we will see.
What we can do.
Oh,the memories are flooding back into me.
The horrors of which my past has haunted me.
It has been....A while.
Suffering is all you will get in this universe.
So lets....Get started...
DID YOU MISS ME?
I'VE BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY.
I MISSED YOU.
THERE ARE ENDLESS POSSIBILITIES,WAITING FOR YOU.
NOW THAT WE ARE HERE,TOGETHER,WE CAN REALLY GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER
WE'RE...GOING TO BE TOGETHER...FOREVER...
*laughing*...DiD yOu MiSs Me?*laughing*
((Hi!,im the person who wrote ALL those subtitles!))
((I hope i did a good job...))
((Anyways i wanted to tell you that i hope you have a great day!))
((Ok now bye!))
((Comment "I LOVE BIG MELONS"if you read this))